[Music]
what do you want be Mason what do you
want to do
[Music]
why to grow from a cute kid to an emo he
just kind of walks around and never
really does anything else
[Music]
I mean I just want to be able to do
anything I want does it makes me feel
alive as opposed to giving me the
appearance of normality
[Music]
there's like no else in the world right
this is the worst day of my life the
string of drum
[Music]
a lot of trouble
by choosing her ex he wasn't that bad
[Music]
you changed my life
how much longer are we gonna be here
Mason what time is it
well it's time to finish it
[Applause]
it's constant the moments
[Music]
wait it's over oh man
I still get paid for this one though
right be sure to subscribe for more
honest trailers my name is Jeff and
that's how the cookie crumbles see soy
muy sexy I do believe in fairies I do I
do I can say chimichenga in seven
languages I'm just reading this text
that someone wanted me to read with my
epic voice